Hello, Dr. Cabricotters. This is session six and new look for cancer. We're talking about how a person
does
It's up developing cancer in their body and how
What systems are present in a person's body to keep a person from getting cancer?
So we talked about some suppressor genes quite briefly last time
No, we could put those into a category of suppressor systems
So we're talking about suppressor again. We're suppressing
Cancer so we're suppressing the growth and rapid replication of cells
So on of the suppressor systems
We have to talk about normal program cell death because that is your number one way and really how all your suppressor genes work is to
stimulate
Poptosis so a poptosis remember is the word we use for normal program cell death. Why isn't the cell died?
We're going to talk next week about receptor site abnormalities
This is
Orge around this
Rectagular picture here is the cell bed braid on the cell bed braid these little grayish things are different receptors for different
That will stimulate different pathways
It inside the cell all this little goblygook of all these technical
abbreviations have to do with different
Intra inside the cell intracellular pathways
It's very complicated. So these intracellular pathways are what we're concerned with with cancer
Oh, you see down at the bottom left that that
That squashed circle that says a poptosis a poptosis
Is a process in the cell
That happens within the cell cytoplasm of all these different pathways. So a number of these different pathways lead to you can see
Some of them go down to it lead to a poptosis. That's what causes cell death
Now if there's a blockage think of that if there's some sort of blockage in any of one of those pathways
It could block the process of a poptosis. So there's a blockage because of a
We talk about cancer causes if there's a virus if there's a toxicity if somebody has a heavy mental toxicity if somebody has some sort of bacterial infection
So how does H. Pylora I work in causing cancer?
It's the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide. How does H. Pylora a bacteria cause cancer?
Is it because the H. Pylora is grown out of control?
Well, not really so H. Pylora causes cancer two ways H. Pylora is a grab negative bacteria that could get inside the cell
Getting anything that's going to get inside the cell that is a foreign
Invader could disrupt intra cellular pathways a many different type of intercellular pathways
If H. Pylora gets inside the cell and mainly affects the mitochondria
You are going to have a decrease in energy production in this person is just going to have fatigue
Many of the viruses actually do that they decrease energy production in the cell and the person ends up with just chronic fatigue
Epstein bar as an example of that
so
But one of the things that H. Pylora does is it gets inside the cell and it blocks these
Apoptotic pathways
So if a person is going to get cancer remember the first thing that has to take place is a broken apoptotic pathway
Another thing that the H. Pylora does is it attaches to an apoptotic receptors
So it can actually take the place of another apoptotic stimulator of that cell membrane
so where the cell membrane
Has a receptor that is considered an apoptotic receptor meeting that
Vitamin D is supposed to attach to that receptor be the key that turns that that lock mechanism that
Protein in that membrane wall to start this activation process that leads to apoptosis
Now the key can't get in that mechanism
So the key can't get in the lock because H. Pylora is stuck there
When we talk about receptor systems last week next week you're going to see that that is really what is going on with
estrogen
Dominated cancers. So breast cancer that is her two positive has to do with
Inability for the eight-all receptor to be stimulated which is an apoptotic receptor
So if there's a blockage on the receptor membrane the cell membrane the receptor
If there's a blockage or a breakdown in that intercellular signaling
Then apoptosis doesn't take place and we have a problem inside the cell
Of this picture. There's another rectangular
Structure that has a red membrane around it. That is supposed to depict the nucleus
And in the nucleus is where you have gene regulation. That's where the DNA is and that's where you have cellular proliferation
That's where you have a rapid replication taking place with a cancer
You can see all the different processes that lead into that that affect gene regulation that affect the DNA
If any of those pathways are broken by the same thing. Let's use H. Pylora
Then it could lead to not only a failure of apoptosis, but now also
Failure adorable replication and instead of that cell replicating every 12 weeks
It's replicating once every three days
And then that cell is replicating another cell with that say break in that pathway
So that's what cancer is. So let's say it was started by H. Pylora
It broke the somewhere in the apoptotic pathway and it broke the stimulation of normal gene
proliferation so though your genes are
Are duplicating your cell is replicating
Every three days instead of every 12 weeks. That's by definition what cancer is
So the suppressor system that we're talking about is really apoptosis. It's really essential
So even if I have a broken replication pathway
So the cell is going to replicate faster if I have a healthy apoptotic pathway
It's going to die the cell will die
So we're not even talking about the immune systems help here
This is just a normal process that's supposed to take place
Whatever the cell is injured
When the cell is aged there's a bunch of different signaling mechanisms that signal apoptosis
There can be a signal from inside the cell and there can be a signal from outside the cell
So apoptosis plays this important role in normal development in a whole wheel of stasis
This is what keeps us healthy. If we didn't have apoptosis taking place
Our bodies would just get bigger and bigger and bigger as we replicate cells
Our liver would explode out of our gut. Well our gut would be exploding. We would be getting larger
So that just doesn't work that way. So as a cell replicates the mother cell eventually dies
It's activated by two things I said something that's going on inside the cell and a receptor
Point from the outside of the cell. So this is where things can get broken
So things can get broken inside the cell or things can get broken at the receptor membrane
Cancer often initiates
Causes is really initiated by DNA damage and should
Technically because of the DNA damage should dead through the intrinsic
apoptotic process should stimulate apoptosis
And that's where the tumor suppressor genes really come in
The p53 is an intracellular messenger and should signal apoptosis
if
replication is starting to take place
So if there's a damage in the DNA
telemere which is going to signal rapid replication
It should stimulate p53 to stimulate apoptosis
So this is where a deficiency in p53
Could lead to cancer
So we'll go back to last week's presentation if this person is
Is being exposed to a lot of chemicals is not being exposed to
cruciferous vegetables
You are setting yourself up for cancer you could say
Well, there's lots of different factors that have to take place in order for someone to get sick
And many different factors that have to take place in order for someone to completely express cancer
So we don't want to pin it on one thing
But we do want to look at lifestyle changes
That's why it's important whether you're trying to recover from disease or trying to prevent disease
To look at the big picture
It's not so much just giving this person chemotherapy
It's going to kill all the cancer and they can continue to live their lifestyle
That is my gripe about even professing it for an oncologist to do
chemotherapy and surgery
And say we've removed the bulk of the tumor and their PET scan is cleaned
That they are cancer-free and they've won the battle
There's a real danger there because the truth is we're never cancer-free
And if you've ever had an diagnosis of cancer
You've got thousands maybe millions of circulated tumor cells that are just waiting to metastasize
So if you go back to the lifestyle that brought you to where you were
The chance of you ended up two to five years later with full metastasis is very possible
So we have to change the maloo
We have to change the foundation of the cell environment
Which if any cancer therapy doesn't look at dietary changes and lifestyle changes
You've completely missed the bone
I cannot tell you how many patients have come to me
And told me that their oncologist said that diet had nothing to do with their cancer
And that was just a fallacy
It's just the ignorance is mind-boggling that's out there
To think that you could just use chemicals to destroy cancer
And then you're going to never get it again is just ridiculous
So normal process is apoptosis
It's an essential process for life in general
Normal cells undergo apoptosis
It responds to stress-inducine events in the cell
Any DNA damage
And dysregulation or a break in that apoptotic cycle is critical for cancer development
It is the first step that really takes place usually
So there's an intrinsic, there's an extrinsic pathway
And we're going to talk about, we spoke a little bit about P53
We're going to talk about other things that activate this
We'll get too deep into that
So resisted, these are the hallmarks of cancer
You could say
Resisting cell death is really usually the first thing
It's not always the first thing that takes place
But it has to be the next thing that takes place after DNA damage
So we're going to walk through all of these little steps here
In the next coming things here
So I hope you're learning something from this
I'm trying to keep the brief, but they're going about 15 minutes, so I apologize
So all right, if this was helpful, I need you to let's do it again
Go ahead and do that
Otherwise, I will see you next week